Um, uh, going to, uh, start
by the way, and I know that,
um, Hemingway, Fitzgerald and Faulkner,
very much iconic figures
of American literature. Um,
and probably you guys are here,
uh,
because you know something
about those offers already.
So I'm not going to be going over a lot
of material that you guys know already.
Instead of will,
I like to do,
is to come up with a little bit of a
material that might be somewhat surprising
to you. And, um, I'm going
to be talking about, um, uh,
free analytics scales are,
this is kind of a critical
paradigm that we'll be using, um,
throughout the semester,
which is the use of three analytics
scales to talk about the authors.
So first of all,
this,
the macro history of the United States
and the world and two techs come to mind
both Hemingway's for whom the bell
tolls and to have and have not,
uh, so that's the largest
possible level. Um,
and then we'll go down a little
bit to the next level, um,
which is, um, still large. Um,
but it has to do with narrative
experiments, um, of modernism.
And the text that we're reading
can all be called moderns text, um,
in one way or another.
Um,
so we'll be looking at the sound of
fury specifically for that register,
that analytic register of experimentation.
Um,
and finally we'll be looking at the
smallest possible scale micro level.
Um, and it has to do with sensory did
housing. It's like all three of them, uh,
are wonderful on sensory details.
But today we'll just be
talking about one tax, uh,
the great Gatsby and what particular
moment when the registering of the sensory
world is very important.
Um, so let me, um,
go to, um, Hemingway and, uh,
talk a little bit about him.
Um,
in many ways as a kind of
a gateway or a guy, uh,
to Google vision of American literature.
Um,
Hemingway was framed much a world
traveler. Um, he, um, you know,
basically we can get a map of the world
by just looking at his writings. Um,
but he had this special love of
the Spanish language. Um, so,
um, for whom the bell tolls will be
reading this in our class, uh, Isabel,
the Spanish civil war.
Uh,
and Hemingway was there as a
war correspondent. Um, and,
but we can see that he actually got
into combat situations right here. Uh,
so, uh, it's, it's, it's, uh, it's really
interesting to think about Hemingway.
It's both a journalist
and also, um, uh, uh,
the novelists. Um, so this the
global dimension of Hemingway,
but also the global diamonds
in the Spanish civil war
itself. It was a civil war.
It was portraying, um, two
sides fighting in Spain. Um,
but it was also very much an international
war, um, in the sense that, uh,
Russia was a part of it. Germany was
DePaul of it. Italy was positive.
Um, so it very much
was a gathering of, um,
a lot of nations, uh,
converging on the soil of Spain.
Um,
and fighting a war that in
name was the Spanish civil war,
but actually in action in terms of
his castle players was very much an
international war. Um, so, um,
this is one level at which
we can understand Hemingway,
is that he really was a player,
um,
in a very large scale map of the world.
Um,
and because he was such a
player on a large scale map, uh,
we shouldn't be surprised that he will
be going to other countries as well and
love loving the Spanish language.
Uh, we're taking him to Cuba. Um, so,
uh, we'll be reading to have and have
not, uh, which is about Cuba. Um,
and this is a very,
um,
unforgettable image of
a Hemingway and Castro.
Uh, we might not know that they
were actually good friends.
Uh, so this is just
something that, you know,
we should keep in mind as we read
Hemingway. Um, and Hemingway actually, uh,
the, as the war ended in 1939, um,
and from 1939 to 1960,
he actually lived in Cuba.
Um, he wrote a lot of is uh,
important novels there to oh man.
And the sea was written when he was
living in Cuba. So, you know, again,
a very important fact to bear
in mind. Um, and this is, um,
the interior of his house in Cuba.
Um,
and I don't know, I'll put all of
this, the PowerPoint on our website,
so you'd be able to see the detail.
But this is a cigar box there was given
to Hemingway, um, and on the cigar,
but the box is as a grant and Mikko
the Cuba great friend of Cuba.
So he, anyway, uh, it isn't,
it right now is not just an American
author, but very much a Cuban, um,
other, um, in Cuba. Um, so, um, we,
we won't actually be talking
about Castro's Cuba to
have and have not actually
took place earlier, but this is just
a kind of a continuing relation, uh,
the Hemingway has to that
country. Um, so, okay.
So we'll move on now to the
next scale of analysis. Um,
and this is the narrative
experiment. Um, the very,
um,
striking a narrative styles that
we see in this body of writing.
Um, and no more so than in
the sound, the fury. Um,
I think that if we've read that novel,
we know that it's impossible just to
read it once and understand of it, right?
This is kind of not really compels us
to go back to read several times, um,
because the level of experimentation,
um, in, in that novel.
So this is from the opening of the sound
of the fury and you guys probably know
that there are four sections
to the sound and the fury. Um,
and the First Section is toe,
uh,
by Benji who's clinically retarded.
So this is all the action is unfolding,
um,
in the mind of someone who's not
really registering the world. Um,
most of us do.
So let's just see how Benji
understands the world,
how he takes in the world.
Did you come to meet Kelly?
If she said rubbing my hands,
what is it?
Whether you're trying to tell Kenny Kelly
smell by trees and like when she says
we were asleep,
whether you're moaning about [inaudible],
you can watch again when
we get to the branch here.
Here's you a Jimson a week he gave
me the flower. Makes no sense,
right? Right. Now it doesn't make
any sense. Okay. So I, I'm sorry,
but I have to tell you that this is
actually a conflation of two moments in
time. The first moment takes place
when Benji was just a young boy.
The second I tell in Italics,
um, takes place when, uh,
Benji is actually 33 years old.
Um,
so we don't usually
tell the story that way,
jumping across such a vast space of time.
Um,
but that's exactly the kind of narrative
technique to Faulkner users in the
sound of fury.
Um,
and the numerous advantages and
challenges to that kind of writing.
Um,
but one interesting fact that
emerges from this little old moment,
um, is that a young white
girl, Kathy is Benji's sister,
a young white girl is seen in intimate
power level with a young black boy who's
luster, the black servant
who's taking care of Benji.
So what could be the connection between
a young white girl and a young black
boy? It turns out that it really
has everything to do with smell.
Benji love Patty and she
smells like trees for him.
I don't think the Bangy actually
registers Kenny as a person.
She's really just a smell to
him. Um, and uh, it, you know,
I think that most of us actually
registered people in that way, you know,
taking one very specific aspect of
other people. But I think they're Benji,
especially those that,
um,
so it is caddies smell that means
everything in the world really to Benji.
Um,
and when luster gives him the Jimson with
it is not exactly the smell of catty,
but it's close enough.
So that luster is actually the closest
that Benji can get to in the very sad
times when he is 33,
when he's really lost everything that he
loves in the wall luster and the Jimson
weed is the closest they can get back
to caddy. So this is the language,
the way their Faulkner's telling the
story is not based on linear chronology.
It is based on the logic of
association in our minds.
And different people have different
logics of association and Benji's logic of
association is completely based on the
sense of smell bits on Sam as well,
but then the smell and the specialist.
So, um, we can tell that, uh,
we can say that in some stance, Hemingway
has taken us to a foreign country,
you know, thing that's to
stay in and to Cuba. Um,
and Fargo has also taken us to a foreign
country in the sense that the mind of a
retarded person is the sort of foreign
country to those of us who are not
retarded. And this is a very
interesting kind of foreign country,
um, to go to, um, and to
steep ourselves in. Um,
so finally, um, we'll move on
to the smallest possible scale,
uh, which is, uh, as, as they related to
what we've just seen in thought now. Uh,
but this was an early moment in the
great gas VA. Um, and it is about daisy,
one of the most famous characters
in American literature. Um,
and this is nick Carraway, the narrator
talking about daisy, his cousin.
Um, so nick is not retarded.
He's highly intelligent,
but um,
his take on daisy is interesting and
that is not necessarily the tech that we
would have to our cousins. Think
about how we think about our cousins.
Probably not nothing like this.
So who voice compel me forward?
Breathlessly as I listen.
Then the glow faded each like discerning,
discerning her with lingering regret,
like children leaving a
pleasant street at dusk,
highly idiosyncratic idiosyncrasy of,
of highly intelligent person.
But in many ways as unusual as Benji's my,
so Nate tends to conflate
different senses.
He's talking about the quality of son
of days a but his youth using visual
images to talk about
that quality of staff.
So they uses voice failing out is like
children leaving the street at Das is
very interesting visual image to
talk about a certain quality of Sar.
Why does he want to do that? Why does
Fitzgeral want to write in that way?
Why is it that the visual register is
being involved in all to talk about all of
the [inaudible].
That's one of the questions that we'll
be thinking about as we move on, um,
in our class. So, um,
so far you've noticed,
um,
that I've associated one scale
of analysis with one author,
right? So Hemingway is associated
with the largest possible scale,
um,
partner with kind of a middle scales
and Fitzgerald with micro level.
Um, it, we could do it that way. Um,
but I don't really want you
to get the impression, um,
that one author is to be associated
only with that one particular scale.
So in the rest of the lecture,
what I'd like to do is to talk about
one phenomenon that is across scale
phenomena.
That is something that invites
experience on all three levels,
on the largest possible scale on this
mid level and smaller scale as well that
all three offers talk
about to some extent,
maybe they don't talk about it and I kind
of frontal away, uh, but they engage in,
in some fashion.
So it's an important event for them.
Um, and it's not surprising that
war should be an important event,
two or three others because the body
of writings that were looking at, um,
really all come right after World War One.
So well one is in some sense the
unspoken horizon ray behind all of his
writings. Um, and, uh,
we'll be talking about war today
and talk about war generally,
um, as the most obvious
level, which is large scale,
uh, geopolitics. Um,
and to some extent when you have
action happening on that scale,
there's a kind of a loss
of individual agency, um,
and the narrow to a problem that comes
with that. Um, this also the deep,
the problem, the
deformation of language, um,
the way that worst get used as
euphemisms in and the conditions of war.
Um, and what that does to
language in general. Um,
and then we'll talk about war
as a psyche phenomenon. Um,
combat trauma and the
psychology of homecoming.
All this worth familiar all is,
uh,
just things that happen when we go to war.
Um,
but we'll,
we'll,
one is especially important to think in
terms of those lives because this is in
many ways the first war, uh, that, um,
that that was not only fought on this
scale that was unprecedented, um,
but also different war
strategies were being tried out.
So one of the very important features
of where we're one was trench warfare.
That this is really what we see here.
Um,
people digging themselves
in and staying in those, um,
trenches from months
and years, really. Um,
and to experience has no more
than people firing at you. Um,
and then being sung in month.
Um, Matt is the most important,
um, sensory material the people
actually remember about the war.
Um, well, well one is, uh, was
is also important because, uh,
chemical warfare was introduced.
Um,
and so in this image, um, we see, uh,
Ashley British soldiers who
suffer from poison gas. And we'll,
we'll one,
I'm just looking at these images.
We can see that this is really not a
glorious why there's no other heroic war.
It is a war that is impossible
to romanticize. Uh, you know,
when you are stuck in those conditions,
there's almost no way you can
prove that you are brave person.
Personal bravery doesn't really come
into play under those conditions of war.
So it is a war that is
impossible to feel good about.
No matter how brave you are,
you can get a sense of passion that
comes from that kind of bravery.
Um, and so, um, there are a
number of consequences, uh,
of that, uh, impossibility of filling,
heroic in possibility of getting any
kind of emotional satisfaction from
fighting. Paul Fussell, who's a very, um,
insightful and important critic wrote
about called the Great War and modern
memory. Um, and I've
kind of a celebrate, uh,
classic on, on one
their Azure. Uh, and he,
this is what he says.
Well,
he claims Om the primal
scene is undeniably horrible,
but there's irony is dynamics of host
of bridge is what horns the memory.
I'm saying that there seems to be one
dominating form of modern understanding
that it is essentially ironic that it
originates in the application of mine and
memory to events with a great one.
Great Warriors. Whoa, whoa one.
Um,
so Paul also claims that
the war's structures,
human experience,
both those who are actually
fighting and civilians back at home,
where people who come back to civilian
life as basically an ironic structure
through which we experience the world.
What does that mean?
We'll be looking more to think about
what it means to experience the world
through the lens of Rna. Uh, but right
now we can also get a little bit of what,
um, first for me is just
from this one passage. Uh,
it has to do with the
dynamics of hope's a bridge.
What does it mean to live without any
kind of hope for yourself or for the
outcome of the war. And sometimes
hope is not even linked to vegetarian,
which is a really radical claim that it
doesn't really matter if you're on the
winning side. That doesn't
really give you grounds for hope.
Why would that be the case? Um, and uh,
and that, and the other claim
that foster was making, um,
is that RNA is basically a
mental structure, the structures,
our memory as well.
It's not just our immediate reaction to
wall when you're going through it that
you can make ironic comments
about things that are happening.
But when you think about it, when you
bring it back to your mind afterwards,
that RNA is the structure by which you
recall something and lift that event over
again.
What does it mean to have an ironic
recall in relation to your own experience?
Um, so let's look at
Paul fussell's claim, um,
through the three authors who have written
a fairly memorable things about those
phenomena out.
And I'm very glad to be able to talk
a little bit about farewell to arms.
We're not reading farewell
to arms in this class. Um,
some of you might have read it on your
own, but this is a celebrated moment,
um, in farewell to arms, um,
talking about the effect
of war on language and how
it makes it impossible for
us to use certain words.
I was always,
this is the protagonist Fredrick Henry.
I was always embarrassed by the worst,
sacred,
glorious and sacrifice and
the expression in vain.
We had heard them sometimes standing
in the rain almost out of earshot.
So the only,
the shower it worse came through and
had read them on proclamations now for a
long time.
And I had seen nothing sacred and the
things that were glorious had no glory and
the sacrifices were like stop loss as
Chicago if nothing was done with the meat
except to Barry, yet abstract
was or just glory, honor,
courage or hello work have seen beside
the concrete needs of villagers,
the number of regimens and a days is
as Hemingway writing in their world to
arms. But in some sense, this
really disrupts the whole
pan in way that we know,
right? The importance of days,
the importance of places, um,
the importance of numbers.
Um,
this is alive long habit for him in where,
and here we can sometimes see the origins
of that way of writing the fairy queen
very economical,
very not really kind of writing,
um,
in is in some sense a response to the
circumstances of war is almost as if warm
makes it impossible to do
a romantic kind of writing.
And Hemingway's writing is the kind
of the counterpoint to a flowery,
uh, to heroic, to
romantic kind of writing.
So on the level of use of was,
so it was just becoming impossible to use.
But I think that, um, irony also
extends to a larger scale, uh,
which has to do really with
the way we tell a story,
whether or not we can tell the
story in a straightforward fashion.
And Paul offers or suggest,
and I like to test this with Hemingway,
is whether or not after World War One,
it is still possible to tell
story in a completely linear,
straight forward fashion.
Um,
is there something about war that makes
it almost necessary in order to tell the
story from the side tower
in a truncated version,
tell it in a jumbled version
as we've seen in Bangi, um,
or tell it in some way that is mixed up,
you know,
all those things that we recognize
knowledge, all three authors,
maybe it has to do with what. So right
now I've sort of just outlined, you know,
some things to look for as
we're reading this office.
One is the twisted logic
of events, um, and um,
that things are just not working out,
not landing where we will
expect them to land. Um,
the possibility of symmetry of blame,
which seems the logical consequence
when we have no heroes. Um,
and our focus retelling of the past,
not looking at the events frontally
but looking at Lurie fashion.
Um, and then there could be
some point in being blurred.
Usually being very is not
a narrative advantage,
but it could be that
under some circumstances,
learners is actually a cultivated
effect and is designed to do something,
you know, so the work that has
been done by being the lyric, um,
understanding as we know something about
ray, how many ways is famous for that,
I'm just being totally,
um,
giving us the minimal expression,
um, understand the emotions, um,
and then the possibility of
content until we've outcome.
So this is just a kind of schematic way
of laying out some of the things that
we're looking for. Um, that
will test once again, um,
by looking at specific
passages. Uh, so you know,
I just said that Hemingway Fitzgerald,
Faulkner or engage well
or one in some fashion,
but I should qualify that by saying
that the engagement is sometimes quite
oblique. So Hemingway actually
fought in world war one.
He was an ambulance
driver. Um, and so he did,
he was actually in the war.
Um,
but he got one that very quickly, he got
wounded after a few months. He was oh,
of commissions and the rest of the ward.
So he didn't actually experience
one on one in any of the way.
Um, and even though he, he talks
about, well one and farewell to arms,
really his deepest experience of war
is a war that came a little later,
which is the Greco, the Turkish
war of a horrendous event. Um,
I think it's safe to say that there
really is there no good guys and that in
that war, both the toast and
agrees with equally reprehensible.
Um, this is an image of the
burning or smirk now, um,
1922 and the first story that we'll be
reading in our time is on the CI as well.
So this is the background
to that Hemingway story. Um,
and I'll be reading you,
um,
two passages by Hemingway to think
about what irony means for Hemingway.
Uh,
for us,
what this is an image of the leader on
the Turkish side and he's actually our to
Turk is actually the founder of
Turkey of present day Turkey.
So a very important historic figure
that also actually figures in Hanaway's
account of that war. Um, so this is, um,
having way this passage is having weight.
Once again going to cover the Greco
Turkish war as a war correspondent,
he was writing for the Toronto
Star. Um, and this is the, uh,
news article that he
sent to the Toronto Star.
It is oil to come out [inaudible] and
company one Mesopotamia for and it is oil
that Great Britain was to keep
my circle 10 the authority.
So the ears that is disappointed and
canal a salad because he shows no
indication to plunge into the fanatical
holy war me yet get the warrant from
Kamala, the businessmen. Okay.
So there's actually has a kind of
current residents as well oil your is um,
and um, was frustrating about Ataturk, um,
to um, this, the, the religious side,
it's not an exam is that he turns
out not to be your fanatic at all.
He's totally cool and completely
deliberate and deliberative in his mouth.
It's not going to plug it into any hand.
Why is water so you're not going to get
someone fighting as fanatical religious
war. War is not going to happen
because of religious fanaticism.
What is going to happen because of the
economic rationale as he coming from the
importance was that is really the irony
that Hemingway as a war correspondent is
pointing to is there some,
was a highly rational,
we can't really say that it's irrational.
While we can really say that the war is
bad because it's irrational because some
was a highly rational,
and this is supremely ironical.
Hemingway is non approval war.
All he's saying is that this,
this award and it's driven
by economic rationality.
So this is one side of RNA is
that things are not lining up.
The good guys don't look like good
guys and the bad guys or bad guys,
not because they look like the bad guy
that we would expect them with expect bad
guys to look like. So it's just, and
it happens. A largest possible scale.
It's really the global geopolitics of
war that's creating this monster that is
Arthur too, but who was also a
model of economic rationality.
Um, so the other, um,
I've bit of irony of voice actually what
we'll be reading is the first story in,
in our time on the key. A smirk. No. Uh,
and this is the concluding
paragraph of that story.
The Greeks were Nice
chaps to the losing side.
The Greeks were nice chaps
to when they evacuated,
they had all the baggage animals
they couldn't take off with them.
So they just broke the four legs and
dump them into the shallow water.
All those muse,
the four legs broken push
over into the shallow water.
It was all pleasant business. My
work. Yes, the most pleasant business.
So,
so much for the brutality of the Turks
and so much for the victim hood of 10
weeks.
Fixing Hood is something that actually
extend from those who experience it into
a condition they can.
They then then confer on other people.
There's no glory.
There's no moral advantage to being a
victim in the war because the victims of
justice reprehensible as vectors.
So this was really,
I think that what Paul
means by saying that,
that this really an abridgment of hole
in a wall like this is that we can't
really go and fight for the weeks,
you know,
because they are the victims
of the Turkish aggressive.
We can't really say that because the
Greeks are aggressive to the aggressors on
their own muse, on their own, um,
animals or transportation. Um, so it's,
it is,
um,
a world in which that is in some sense
that has been emptied or moral meaning
empty, the moral virtue. Um,
and to the extent that that makes
it impossible to take size with NSL
satisfaction is very,
very desolate landscape,
emotional as well as moral landscape.
So this is really what irony means for
Hemingway is that it is an impossible
place to inhabit.
It is unbearable to
talk about it directly.
It was straightforward way.
And the only way you can talk about it,
it's being ironic and using, talking
about it in a particular tone of voice.
So very important component of RNA is
to tone of voice that says our census.
I'm pulling this,
we'll use our ears to,
to Hemingway as we read
these words on the page. Um,
so let's move on now,
um,
to Fitzgerald and the Great
Gatsby Fitzgerald, um,
Ashley, um, did not have,
um, a very extensive, um,
experience of world war one
either. He actually, um, and he,
he enlisted but he didn't actually
get to fight in world war one.
So this is a really interesting,
um,
reaction of someone who
wants to talk about the war,
as in some sense the central event
of his generation. Um, but we,
we didn't actually have a kind
of a personal acquaintance, uh,
without central event. So this is
from the great Gatsby theme. Um,
and uh, is, uh, at this point, uh,
we haven't been introduced to Gaspe right,
because you guys know that nick Carraway
is the one who's been telling the story
for good part of the time
as the great Gatsby begins,
and he's just meeting this fellow,
um,
that he's making conversation
with your face is familiar.
He said politely once you in the
first division in a war while yes,
I was in a 28 infantry.
I was in the 16th until
June, 1918. I knew,
I've seen you somewhere before we talk
for a moment about some wet gray little
villages in France. Okay. I can tell you,
we can go to the gas and see that
this is taken from the great Gatsby,
but it could have been written
by Hemingway. Right, exactly.
All those points that he makes,
if they were to arms about important
of the number of your division dates,
places Fitzgerald rise
exactly as Hemingway.
So has people would write under conditions
because those are the only details
completely on the emotional,
factual play numbers
playing geographical facts.
Those are the only things you can bear
to name because to name anything else is
in some sense an insult
to your own experience.
And in South Sioux English language.
Um,
so I don't think that,
you know,
most of us actually talk thing
about the great Gatsby, um,
as a war novel and it is
not. So don't, you know,
don't think that I'm trying to create a
reading of the great Gatsby based on the
importance of over one note,
uh, is a one that one novel. Um,
but it is difficult that this person,
that nick is talking to
his gas Gatsby of course,
and that they do have
world war one in common,
that they both actually were
combat soldiers in World War One.
Um, and that's part of the
bond between Nate and gas pain,
what it means for that to be beginning of
a relationship between the two of them.
Um, so in that sense, the great
Gatsby is shadow by Whoa, whoa one.
And we can think of various ways in which
one or the phenomenon of war functions
as a shadow and unspoken, barely
alluded to, but nonetheless,
not inconsequential,
not trivial event that we
should bear in mind this week.
Read on about Gatsby and the bottle neck.
Um,
so one other,
um,
finally shouldn't be surprised that
we'll be moving on to Faulkner.
Um,
and I should
tell you something about
Faulkner, which is, um,
really vary on the heroic. I
mean, we've been talking about,
one is a very unheroic out war, but, um,
foreigners own conduct.
Um,
it's especially on heroic father actually
went to Canada in 1918 to list in the
Royal Air Force. Um, so he
enlisted, never saw action.
Um, his brother actually was
seriously wounded in world war one.
Um,
but for the rest of his life,
farming actually claim that he fought.
He fought in world war one.
There's not something that he claimed
for awhile, you know, not like 19,
19 or 19,
2019 for these three is still claiming
to his nephew that he was in action in,
well, we'll want me, this is kind
of a shocking fact about Vulcan.
I don't know what to do with that except
that this just bear in his biography.
So, uh, Faulkner writes to his
nephew, Jimmy Faulkner. Um,
I would have liked for you to have
had my dog tag Royal Air Force,
but I lost it in Europe, in Germany.
I think that the Gestapo has it.
I'm very likely on the records right now.
It's a dead brother's flying officer spy.
So,
um, well, I mean, you know, it's, um,
that's just a fact and we can
do what we want with that. Um,
Faulkner did write a novel,
um, Carl, um, soldiers, uh,
home. Uh, it, um, I'll,
I'll give you the reference. His,
his, his, his fits first novel. Um,
it's actually about a veteran coming
back. Um, so I will put that on,
on the, on, on the website. Um,
so he actually does write about
what we're one, uh, but, um, he,
for, for the most part, he's not known
as someone who writes about whoa one. Um,
and instead, um, he actually, uh,
we can say that there are
shadows of a war in of Whoa,
one in ice writings about
the American civil war,
which is obviously what is
appropriate to partner to write about.
Um,
and he's not making anything up when he's
writing about the American civil war.
But what is interesting about Faulkner's
writing about the American civil war is
that after three orders,
war is actually only five minutes.
Ashley,
the only order that gives us
who gives us a huge growing,
idealistic,
possibly romantic image of
someone who did not fight in Whoa,
whoa.
One can actually give us
a utopian account of war.
I think that is interesting that
Hemingway would not be capable of writing
anything like this.
Even about the civil war though he's
idealistic by the civil war as well.
Um,
partner is the only person because of
his complicated relation to all one there
for him.
The civil war is actually
in the affirmative moment
in a kind of twisted counter
intuitive when, so this is a
novel. Um, W won't be reading,
but it's a great novel.
So I encourage you to read this on your
own if you have a chance after this
class. Um, but it's, it's um, is about,
is really about the civil wars,
the background to the novel or in the
sense that it doesn't really appear in it.
Um, but a good part of it, um,
some of it is about the women left behind.
Um,
and I'll just read you this moment
and then we can talk about it. Now.
There's two white women and a negress,
not as three Negros are three
wise now even it's three women,
but merely as three creatures who still
possessed in need to eat but took no
pleasure in it,
the need to sleep but from no
joy in awareness or regeneration.
We grew intended and
harvested with our own hands,
the food we ate made and work that garden
just as we cope and ate the food which
came out of it with no distinction
amount of three of us of age or color.
It was as though we were
one being interchangeable.
And in this remanent um,
we already have seen in the sound
of the fury that for the races to be
interchangeable and in this women in
between Kelly and luster is a good thing
for far right.
And for here,
the civil war is what enables that
breakdown of racial distinction to take
phase.
Usually interchangeable is
not really a good quality.
Um, for, for us it's an insult
to our individuality. Um,
but here it is under the circumstances
of their probation when all you can do is
just to keep your body flows,
just to make sure that um,
you can put something into your,
when that is the basic condition of life
and when everyone has to work towards
the fulfillment of that condition,
um,
then raise really doesn't
matter. So this is a really, um,
for Faulkner really emblematic moment.
Um,
when wise as well as blacks
have to work just as hard.
That labor is just a given for the
mysteries as for the slaves. Um,
and when there's just
complete commingling of lives,
um, in, in, in, in, in every
aspect of daily life. Um,
for Faulkner that is one of the
consequences of the civil war is that even
though there is a battle going
on, um, and deadly consequences,
the battle, um, that are
dividing the nation in one sense,
you know,
nothing can be more divisive than still,
even though the nation is
being torn apart by war.
The real is strange kind of healing,
a strange kind of unity.
This coming from that division,
which is the very local,
very personal,
everyday unity between those who are
left behind to 10 for themselves and the
necessity of acting as one.
So it's three people,
blacks and whites acting as one
and war as the necessary condition.
It's really the genetic ground for that
kind of configuration of three people
acting as if they were of one
mind and one body. It is a soup,
keenly Utopian vision for war.
Um,
and ironically both for good and new
[inaudible] Faulkner who never fought in
world war one who is capable
of imagining that Utopian, um,
a possibility. So, you know,
I would say that that this is a kind
of RNA that Paul Fussell wasn't really
thinking about reflux for him. Irony
basically as a kind of a negative anomaly.
But I would argue that we can actually
also expand poff Aso's those inside to
say that the irony of war is such that
one of the counter intuitive outcomes
will actually include an
affirmative understanding of war.
Um, and actually we see this all the
time. The bond amount, comrades, he will,
you know, gis bonding. That's just
a phenomenon that we know about.
Um, and we're following is really talking
about in some sense is the similar bond
amount, the women, um,
similar Paolo to this kind of important
emotional and social bond under
conditions of great divisiveness of all,
which is to show that there's
actually no good resting clothes. Um,
and this is really what I was saying about
all three of others is that, you know,
I think that all of us want to
bring to rest at some point and,
you know, they do come to
rest in our own minds. Um,
but I think that it's always
possible to give yet another twist to
interpretation,
uh,
while it's going on and the range of
possibilities that emerge from any one
event.
Um,
so this really was wonderful and
challenging about those authors.
Is that something that seems to come
to an end one level, Ashley? You know,
if we just look at the largest
hospital level in a divisiveness, um,
on the level of Oomph, geopolitics, uh,
it turns out that this actually unify
and level on a much smaller scale. Right?
So what is, was themes a tragedy? Um,
on one level can turn into a kind
of a comedy of those straight,
straightforward along the
either the comedy in the
sense that allowing some hope
to emerge. So I would have
met Paul Fussell's, uh,
argument about their brichman
of hope in some way as well.
Is that yes,
there is an abridgment of hope,
but there's also the possible
reconstitution of hope,
um, and what we're seeing in absolutely.
Absolutely. Yes, in some sense,
the reconstitution of hope. So
I'm good. Stop right here. Um,
and once again,
um,
those of you who didn't
get to came in late,
let me just say that I'll be talking a
little bit about writing in this class.
This class fulfills the railing and
requirement and also as all of you to sign
both the signup sheet and also
put down on the index cards, uh,
your preferences for sections.